ben shapiro is the author of the
authoritarian moment
how the left weaponized america's
institutions against descent and host
of the ben shapiro show he joins us now
ben
i wish that i was surprised by what i
saw play out in front of us today
then again i live in the great
commonwealth of virginia
where we still have governor ralph
northam who literally everyone called on
to resign
and is still there campaigning across
the country uh campaigning across the
the counties today for his uh would-be
successor what are your thoughts on what
you saw today
from leticia james and your thoughts on
andrew cuomo
you know governor cuomo came into office
to grab ass and kill the elderly and
he's all out of elderly
and the fact that that latisha james uh
you know
laid out this enormous case again about
sexual harassment and sexual pressure
and and retaliatory work environment and
all of this and then she
said and i'm not going to do anything
about it kind of tells you how this is
about to play out you'll recall as you
just mentioned that everyone called in
ralph northam to resign and then
joe biden was campaigning with ralph
northam the rule in the democratic party
at least
is that you either die a hero live long
enough to become a villain or live
even longer than that and then become a
hero again with whom you campaign and
fundraise
you know one of the things that your
book really touches on is the demand
that people have
in this time to have more authority from
government even as
the faith and institutions decays
there's this odd thing that happens
where
as we've seen you know happen in mexico
and places around the world
where more authority is given to these
folks who have already shown themselves
uh
completely terrible when it comes to
using it do you believe in this instance
that cuomo is just going to hold on to
power
as hard as he can and just keep fighting
back against this ignoring what biden is
saying
ignoring what other party leaders are
saying and just uh you know
taking the lesson that as long as you
have that authority you should never
give it up
absolutely no one wants to be al franken
be the guy who left office when they
could have just stayed
and then lived it through i actually
think what you're probably about to see
from governor cuomo is sort of a wag the
mask situation in which
the delta variant is used as an excuse
for him to push
new measures that are really
authoritarian in nature and then he'll
be cheered by the press
again for not being ron desantis because
there really is a desire by a lot of
people out there to be controlled from
above
and even if their leaders are corrupt
and venal and terrible the way that
governor cuomo is remember
all of this controversy is not about how
he killed half the elderly people in new
york right the doj actually dropped an
active investigation into his cover-up
of that we're just talking
about something we've known for a long
time which is that he treats women
horribly
the the fact for cuomo is that if he
wishes to regain any sense of popularity
and credibility
my guess is that he's going to go big
again once more on covet
you know how corrupt the media is when
it comes to covering these types of
situations
for politicians who have the ideological
views that they have
or close enough to it they have the
right party letter after their name
i know that in northam's case as soon as
it became apparent that he wasn't going
to be
replaced he wasn't going to be standing
down the media essentially went silent
and pretended like this wasn't something
that they needed to still be asking
about
do you expect democrats to actually have
to answer
for what's going on here with andrew
cuomo in the coming weeks or do you
believe similarly the last time around
and certainly knowing his connections
over at cnn that he's going to be able
to escape that kind of media pressure
oh no this will be one news cycle and
then go on it was a news cycle a few
months ago and then it was gone so i
would expect this to be
exactly the same thing all we have to do
to figure it out is just watch the human
windsock kristen gillibrand
and she'll tell us in a couple of weeks
whether or not this is blown over
you know your book is a very interesting
and timely one because it speaks to i
think all of these different things
we're worried about in the wake of this
pandemic that
america is going to invest even more
authority
in our governmental leaders who have
shown themselves so incapable of rising
to this moment and so terrible
at actually putting forth policies that
made things better in so many instances
what can be done to push back against
this authoritarian impulse
as we see it across the country what can
individuals do
in their communities and states to make
sure that this doesn't happen
we really do need to band together at
this point there is no question that if
we get together
a group of intransigent and aggressive
people together with our allies that we
do formulate
the majority i think that there's been a
a very hardcore minority of left-wingers
who've been able to cow people into
silence and then move forward
incrementally and a lot of people out of
politeness or out of apathy have done
nothing
i think that the left has pushed too far
too fast and i think the blowback is
coming and 2022 is just going to be the
beginning of it
thank you ben and good luck with the
book thank you so much for joining me
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else